and was a postdoctoral scholar at
stanford subsequent to that
so without further ado vivek please go
ahead
so i can't share still for some reason
yeah uh
are you able to unshare pedro i i tried
it says that i
haven't okay sorry yeah there you go
please go ahead can you see this yeah
okay cool uh awesome uh thanks for uh
the introduction i'm very excited to
follow pedro because uh
in some sense he made a lot of points i
wanted to make
which and i'm going to present
a slightly different perspective of
essentially some of the points that
came up in the discussion after his talk
so this is joint work with my
collaborators and students listed
below and the starting point of this
work
is uh really this question you know
neural networks seem to be so good
they seem to be winning awards you know
running the one mile marathon
you know one minute marathon and all
that so um
what are they really doing i mean just
because and at a more abstract level
if i give you a machine that makes
successful predictions
does this mean that this machine
understands and under the system that
it's working with
and i'm going to argue not necessarily
and
uh let me give you an illustration from
this event this eclipse that took place
in ancient greece in 585 bc
it's just one of these run-of-the-mill
solar eclipses but
the reason this was an interesting
phenomenon is this guy
thales of myelitis was he successfully
predicted the eclipse before it happened
there's evidence that shows that he
didn't know how to do it by himself we
learned it from babylon in astronomers
and so on
but that's not the point so what we have
here is thales having predicted an
eclipse
can we say that they knew how eclipses
worked just because they were able to
make a prediction
and the answer it's pretty conclusive
that no
the first understanding of how eclipses
work the cosmological
arrangements uh came about a century
after the existence of series
so using um modern terminology
what thales and others did is
essentially they data mined observations
of you know cycles and eclipses and said
oh if there is a lunar eclipse today
every 19 years from now about 19 ish
years from now there will be a lunar
eclipse in the same place
if there's a solar eclipse it's the same
cycle but there's some uncertainty
because the solar eclipse is not seen
everywhere in the world but they had no
clue about you know the earth and the
moon and the sun being organized in
certain ways which we know now
i'm going to argue that neural networks
are doing something like that
they are finding patterns in data this
that leads to
frighteningly accurate predictions if
you look at only benchmarks
but just because a system makes an
accurate prediction
does not imply that it actually
understands what
anything about what's going on and this
is kind of related to pedro's point
at the end of this talk in fact what i
think neural networks end up doing is
they latch on to spurious patterns
not necessarily always but they can
latch onto curious patterns in the data
and this is really a recipe for failure
let me give you a couple of examples of
these kinds of failures
so here's a an image and there's a task
called visual question answering you're
given an image and you're asked to
answer a question about this image so
this is a cluttered desk
and let's say we if you give the
question where is the penguin
this system says with like 65
probability that there's a penguin on
this
desk and it's on the table and if you're
still looking for the penguin let me
help you out there is a penguin on the
table
and this seems amazing i mean this most
people don't spot the penguin
and this seems really cool but if you
literally take the same system
and ask the for the same image you can
ask
is there a penguin on the image in the
image and the system says no with 100
confidence so we have this uh
weirdly sort of a quantum penguin here
that both exists and does not exist
and of course only one of these answers
can be correct um
unfortunately today's state of the art
is uh is
innocent of any kind of theory of the
world
what let's let me give you another
example um
now this is a task that i like to work
with called natural language inference
and
i'll be using this task as a running
example through the task
through the talk you're given two
sentences a premise and a hypothesis
the sentence the premise here is before
it moved to chicago the aerospace
manufacturer boeing was the largest
company in seattle
and the hypothesis is uh given the
premise can we say
that boeing is a chicago-based aerospace
manufacturer
and you know you can have either if the
premise entails the hypothesis or the
premise contradicts the hypothesis or
they are unrelated
so which is called neutral so if you
give this pair of sentences to
one of the state-of-the-art measures you
know systems today
um it says that it's quite likely that
the premise entails the hypothesis which
seems pretty cool i mean uh
uh this may not seem like a very
complicated sentence but it involves
a few uh you know jumps that you have to
do to get to the answer
again seems pretty impressive but let's
uh
uh it's super easy to make these systems
fail
so let's take these three sentences p h
and z
p says john is on a train to berlin and
h
says john is traveling to berlin so
clearly uh
he entails that most people would agree
that uh if john's on a train to berlin
he's traveling to berlin
then you can ask what about h and z h
contradicts
if he's traveling to berlin right now he
can't be having lunch in berlin at the
same time
so h contradicts three and the system
would predict that also
now you can ask what about the
relationship between p and z
and imagine that there's a system that
says there's no relationship between p
and v clearly there's a problem um
a system cannot simultaneously hold
these three beliefs
if p entails h and h contact z then p
should contradict c
it this is an invariant that we can
write down in logic
without actually knowing uh you know
which sentence we are talking about
which
three sentences we are talking about and
yet as
a reportedly state of the art natural
language inference system that gets
90 plus percent uh
accuracy or something on the benchmark
while it's this invariant on like
more than half of a large collection of
people so it's clear that
these systems are essentially just
pattern matching without understanding
what's going
what's going on so the question uh in
the context of this example
is can today's neural networks use
theory of this kind in the form of
invariant
in order to guide their how they fit the
data
so the starting point of this work that
uh
my students and i've been doing for a
few years now is really
uh are we when we build neural networks
uh
with uh for all sorts of tasks are we
really modeling
problems or are we modeling just the
benchmark test sets
and the challenge is we need modeling
strategies that
somehow rely on a theory or at least or
maybe even better maybe expose the
theory
because otherwise i think we're just
guessing equations
in high dimensions without understanding
anything about what they're doing
so the the the contrast here is are we
behaving like thales
who gets the equations in the eclipse
space
or are we behaving are we trying to get
a
uh you know work with the philosophy of
the underlying phenomena and work with
that
so my uh i would like to argue that
instead of
the problem the reason we are stuck in
this uh
equation guessing game is because we
seem to be
you know forcing ourselves to only learn
from labeled examples and we should be
learning from knowledge
instead what do i mean by that i i claim
knowledge is
data i mean that i don't think anyone
would disagree with that
um more importantly today's machine
learning is heavily based on this idea
of
having to annotate examples and uh
you know building models on top of
labeled examples but good data sets are
expensive to make
they take expertise they take time
it's not easy sometimes it might be
easier to write rules about
what we expect a model to do and this
could express invariants about
the problem or it could express
inference rules about various parts of
various kind components of the system
this could be
stated as universally quantified
statements like if you have
if two sentences don't have any words
that match each other
imagine that match is a predicate then
the
the two sentences cannot entail or
contradict each other
and i want also i want all mod i would
like to train models that satisfy this
rule as much as possible and how do you
do that
so where can knowledge be involved um
you can think of injecting knowledge
into a machine learning system in
multiple places
you can think of it as you know
influencing model design
knowledge can change how we train the
model uh by changing
the kind of objective that we are
optimizing
or they can not
can enforce congruency in predictions
the last part is really structured
learning and prediction pedro spoke
about that and
it can be difficult you know you might
have to deal with computational
expense you know inference issues and
such things
another line of my work involves
structured output and
structure output prediction and i i
spend my
other life doing that but this talk is
all about the first two things
um can how do we change the model uh
you know a neural network model design
with logic
or how do we change the way in which
models are trained with logic
in order to kind of uh you know unify
these two worlds
uh we have this we have on one hand
neural network land on the other hand we
have logic land
and i would like to merge them let's
look at what each of them give us
neural networks are essentially
differentiable compute there are
fantastic
libraries uh massive industrial backing
and essentially it's super easy to use
high school students
start using pie tarts before they know
anything about machine learning
and that's the world we live in on the
other hand
neural networks are really hard to
supervise except we are labeled examples
and there is some magic that happens
inside them through all these dozens of
layers of
anonymous units that are in them for
starter logic
is expressive you can
state rules easily and it's a natural
way in which domain experts can
work with a problem unfortunately logic
is not differentiable and as a result
the whole
infrastructure that exists for neural
networks doesn't really work well
with logic what we want is of course
both of these things
so i'm going to talk about a direction
that my students and i have been
playing with which seems very promising
and there are some caveats that
maybe i'm going to hide and maybe some
of you will notice
um there are three challenges when we
want to uh
unify logic with neural networks neural
networks as i said are
full of anonymous units of compute uh
what we need
are somehow to uh you know so to
start the process we need to connect the
rules
the predicates in the rules that we are
writing with neural networks
the second thing is we need to make
logic differentiable because we have
essentially given ourselves a design
constraint that we are going to work
with this
differentiable compute the third one is
how do you use
such differentiable logic so let's go
through these uh
one at a time so
i claim that all neural networks expose
some interfaces
in the form of nodes that have some
external mean
i'm going to use a natural language
inference as an example to illustrate
this
so imagine you have this black box this
is black box that
takes two sentences john is on a train
to berlin and john is traveling to
berlin
and it does something and it makes a
prediction that the premise entails the
hypothesis
well even though the entire in internals
of this network might be
opaque we do have three things that
have that are accessible to us the
inputs in the output
in this case the three because there are
two inputs
so we can think of any neural network as
expressing
a predicate over the inputs so in this
case you have a predicate entail
which has two arguments premise and
hypothesis
we can also think of any deterministic
properties of the inputs as
uh as predicates that we have access to
so these
uh these form the interfaces that we
have
sometimes uh we can open up the black
box
some internal nodes in a network have
some meaning by design
so i could have a node here for example
that's an attention node
that says that the you can think of it
as what's the probability that the word
traveling is aligned with the word train
i can think of
that particular node as a soft
probability for this predicate or a soft
version of this predicate align train
and travel
so we we get these uh uh
not every node in the neutral network
might have a name
of this kind but some nodes in the
networks might have names that we can
work with
this is a important component that we'll
need
i'm calling them named neurons these are
nodes inside a computational
computation graph that has some external
uh meaning named neurons give us the
vocabulary for writing down rules
so you could have a neuron a neurons
just
a fancy name here for some function
that gives you a probability for
an alignment between these two phrases
and i can
treat it as if i'm working with this
uh this predicate called align so i'll
use lowercase for
neurons and uppercase for predicate so
that's the first challenge how do we
bridge predicates in the rules that we
have with neural networks well we
restrict ourselves to writing rules
about name neurons
the second question is how do we make uh
logic
differentiable uh there are many
approaches for this
and the idea that we've been playing
with
involves triangular norms they provide
systematic relaxation of logic and some
of them
are even continuous and some of them are
sub-differentiable and so we can work
with them
so if you have these four standard
boolean operators their inputs and
outputs
live in the set 0 comma 1
and i can relax them to using different
you know named relaxations or even
otherwise
and each operator becomes a function
that we can now plug in to a neural
network
and what it gives us is
functions that are essentially in the
range
zero to one one cool thing is uh the
lucas elix relaxation
is essentially built out of rectified
linear units so any
uh self-respecting neural network
library today has this stuff built in so
we can just
use this uh out of the box uh just as an
example of how these relaxed operators
work we can look at the conjunction
uh if you think of the conjunction as a
function that maps
zero comma one to the four uh to uh you
know the standard
definition of the punjab conjunction we
can essentially connect the space
between
this thing in any sort of a monotonic
way and each of those gives you a
relaxation and when each of those is a
different relaxation
all these relaxations agree with the
definition of the conjunction
at the four boundary points and
internally they are just
a surface there's a question of which of
these is the best
to use and in we found that
it turns out for reasons that i'm not
entirely happy about the product scene
seems to be
uh the best relaxation but that
we can keep that discussion offline so
uh the short version of this thing is if
you want to use relaxed logic uh
using a genome relaxation seems to be
promising so next question is how do you
use this
these relaxations what can logic do for
neural networks
essentially one way or another either
through what i'm talking about or
through
standard structured models knowledge
introduces
inductive bias and that's important
in the specific context that i'm talking
about we can introduce inductive bias by
essentially modifying the network
architecture
to pro to to be more amenable
to satisfying the constraints we have or
by essentially imposing a preference
uh to uh during the optimization process
that
we have so that uh models that violate
constraints are penalized so let's uh
i'm going to give cartoon examples of
each of these things
so let's see how we can change the
network architecture
so imagine that we have a neural network
with
two layers and actually many layers i'm
just showing two of them
there's a layer of the a's and the layer
of the bs
and there are many layers in between
them in particular i'm going to focus on
this
node here b1 b1 depends on some inputs
x that are not shown here in addition to
this network let's say we also have this
rule
that says a1 and a2 implies b1
so that involves these three nodes here
so these are the
name these are the predicates that we
have and this a1 the lower case these
are the named neurons
well i can convert the left hand side uh
into a soft uh function using lookup
standards logic
and i'm going to call that b uh it's a
function that
who's high if if b takes a higher value
that means the left hand side is more
likely to be true
i can replace b here with a constrained
node
essentially adding a short circuit from
the a's to the b's
through this distance i'm calling these
these distances
and uh introduce one extra
uh input to uh that particular node here
uh if you want to kind of go over this
in a little bit more uh
detail imagine that the row on the slide
is a positive number
if d is high and rho is high then
if a1 and a2 are true then this b1 the
the expression inside this thing becomes
large and as a result
b1 becomes closer to one b1 becomes
larger
if a1 and a2 are false then well
the a1 and a2 have nothing to say about
b and the value of b depends on whatever
was
coming from the w and x so we're going
to replace such
node the original node b with an
augmented node b prime
and we'll do this systematically this is
just a cartoon example you can imagine
that
we can essentially perform this
operation
it's a compile time operation we can do
this before any training happens give me
a neural network give me some rules
and i'll marry them together to give you
a neural net a network an augmented
network that you can use
there is there are there is this
additional term row here which we think
of as a hyper parameter you can think of
it as
deciding how strongly is the constraint
enforced
if rho is infinity then b b1 prime
is going to essentially ignore what x
says
it's not going to uh look at that if rho
is zero
it's going to ignore the constraint
okay so that's one version of things we
can change the network architecture
using uh by uh changing um
using the rules the other way of
thinking about it is we can
keep the network that we have sometimes
we have neural networks where we don't
really know what's happening inside them
we don't really get to control them
instead we can regularize learning
and let's see how that works to see that
we need to kind of
think about labeled examples and
knowledge
in a uh in a uniform way
or all label data and constraints to
together can be written as you know
rules of this kind l implies r
uh for example i can write rules like if
p
given three sentences if the sentence p
entails the sentence
h and if the sentence h entails the
sentence v then p should intensity
this is a universally quantified rule uh
it's of the form
l implies r if i have a labeled example
let's say i have a pair
p and s that's labeled with something
let's say entail i can write this as
uh true entails uh implies p comma h
so it's of this form uh l implies r so
all my data and all my knowledge can be
written as this
one thing so anything that we build on
top can assume that we have
rules of this kind importantly knowledge
that we have doesn't really depend on
labeled examples we can just use
unlabeled data
and use work with these rules
now you remember that these rules are
written in terms of these predicates
that
we have some probabilities for from the
neural network
the goal of learning is to find a model
that makes all these rules true
that's what we want because that we want
the knowledge to be uh
the constraints to be satisfied and all
the labeled examples to be uh
to you know to get the the model to
assign a label that the data says
so we want all the rules of this form to
be true we can't do that because that's
a discrete search problem
instead we want to find models that
maximize a t norm relaxation
um and at this point you can use
whatever t norm you want you can use any
neural network you want you can use any
library
and any optimizer a cool observation
that we found
is if you use the product relaxation
and just have labeled examples what we
end up getting using this formula is the
popular cross entropy loss
which is uh a different way
uh at least the third or the fourth
different
perspective on cross entropy uh that
i've seen which is neat
all right in the interest of time i'm
not going to show you
a whole bunch of results and i'm just
going to uh
give you a flavor so do these rules help
neural networks
just one example the given the running
example that we've had
imagine that we want to penalize uh
a model that makes these kinds of uh
these three beliefs
that has hold these three beliefs
simultaneously i can write uh
transitivity constraints of this kind
for example if p entails h and h and dlc
we shouldn't tell z
i can also have another constraint that
says if a sentence contradicts another
if p contradicts
h then h should contradict v and this
should be true for all p
h um we can literally just compile these
rules
into regularizers and feed it into an
optimizer
and give it to the state-of-the-art
models based on
bert or pick your favorite and we found
that
uh i'm not going to go over the details
i'm just showing a plot that
measures uh how badly do these models
fail
blue is the original model that was not
aware of these
rules and red is the constrained model
and the horizontal axis here is adding
more data
first thing is just adding more data
does not mean that the model gets better
which is in some sense anathema to
how some people approach this uh just
throw more data models get better and it
turns out models get better only from a
certain perspective
so adding more data does not necessarily
mean we get better models
if you want better models models that
are more
in some sense logically meaningful or
they
agree with any invariants that you
specify you need to actually ask the
models to do that
and that's the second point uh these
kinds of logic based regularizers
seem to help with consistency without
interestingly adding any computational
overhead because we can just
piggyback off all the improvements that
have happened in uh you know industrial
and general network libraries a more
broader uh
a more broad summary of some experiments
that we've been
playing with we've had successful
experiments across multiple different
tasks for both ways of
introducing knowledge across natural
language inference reading comprehension
some work involving you know digit
recognition and such things
information extraction the general
flavor is when we have less data
adding knowledge gives you better
statistical models
and using these kinds of approaches we
can
inject in variances into learned systems
which
surprisingly don't seem to be learned
even when we give a lot of data
so let me start wrapping up i started
the talk
by asking the successful prediction
implied understanding and
i don't think it does and thales
provides a nice counterexample
and if we don't think of uh you know the
the underlying problem and just treat it
as a pure
end-to-end uh black box learning
we can have systems
that can be pretty lousy uh
in uh in annoying ways
um and what we need are systematic
approaches that
integrate symbolic knowledge with neural
networks
because knowledge gives you inductive
bias and inductive bias is
necessary when you don't have a lot of
data
for the last few years my students and i
have been playing with this
idea of using relaxed logic and it seems
to be a really promising idea
thanks i'll be happy to take questions
thank you vivek for a wonderful talk let
me uh clap for everybody
beautiful um questions please
anybody uh okay so let me
ask you a few questions so uh you talked
about this relaxed logic
um that there was there were three forms
i think product cordelian and
luka civic yeah logic
[Music]
and and so you mentioned that
using product was better than the other
two or
uh in some of your experiments yeah
so this was interesting um so
interestingly this thought uh
came into uh this question that uh i
think
i remember right it was a following a
conversation with pedro at some new rips
or something
uh where we were wondering like what do
these relaxations actually mean
and i started playing with okay let's
not worry about what they mean given
that there are so many relaxations is
there one that's better than the other
um so it turns out that
none of them are actually sound
um because they
they essentially give up on certain
axioms of logic
but in practice the product relaxation
seems to be
seemed to be the best uh just in
experiments because uh
it offered better gradient
uh so it was more of a pragmatic reason
why the product relaxation was better
there was another sort of a less
empirical
reason why the product was better but
according to that
essentially by asking which relaxation
preserves the
consistently assigns high values to all
pathologies
um and uh of course all of them fail
uh but some are some fail worse than
others
and product and lucas savage were better
than
anything else but uh it's really a
practical point
in practice product works better simply
because
uh the gradients are not zero every
in a large part of the space looks like
it has this constant
here and that essentially gives you zero
gradients and that
leads to learning not really working
okay and i had one more question so you
mentioned that you can do this surgery
to the neural network before training
and add this logical uh
nodes if you will right that augment the
uh yeah this picture uh this is
i wonder how you do that though like how
do you exactly
go about modifying the computational
graph is there an automated
compilation that you can do from rules
to modifying the network
so the version that we did for this uh
so that's a good question
uh the version that we did for uh the
paper that we
wrote on this uh the automated compiler
was a grad student
i'm still hoping that i can convince
someone to
make this an automated process because
it is really just mechanical
right now i'm using this really cool
tool called grassroot
any additional questions
if not thank you again vivek for a great
talk thank you
thanks uh mark would you like to go
ahead and share your screen
so while mark does that uh
let me introduce mark so he's a he's